Brian the Johnson the writer/director of
the last mark hamill you know am is Luke
Skywalker Daisy Ridley aka raid Adam
driver kylo Ren Oscar Isaac Poe Dameron
John boyega Finn
Kelly Maria Tran they do character Rose
laura dern plays Admiral hold o domhnall
gleeson general hux Wendling as i
captain phasma and andy serkis as
himself welcome to the press-conference
guys thank you all for being here
joining together in one place to talk
about this movie which you guys have
seen but they have not but they have a
lot of questions for you so Ryan what
would you say differentiates the last
Jedi from the force awakens but also the
Empire Strikes Back as a second chapter
in a trilogy so yeah it's it's you know
it's a second movie in the trilogy and I
think we've been kind of trained to
expect it'll be a little darker and
obviously it looks a little darker and
the thing is though it for me I loved
the tone that was a step that of the
original films and also that JJ cut
captured in the force awakens of fun and
that's like to me it's a Star Wars movie
first and foremost we were trying to
make it feel like a Star Wars movie and
that means you have the intensity and
you've got the Opera but it also means
that it makes you come out of the
theater wanting to run in your backyard
grab your spaceship toys and make them
fly around you know and that's a key
ingredient to it so so we're gonna go to
some intense places in the movie but I
hope also it's fun it's funny I know you
guys have you've seen it what's up the
cast who was in the force awakens how
would you say this film feels
differently I just think the stories the
story is moving moving forward I just
feel like that JJ had
foundation of force awakens that was
pretty good and now it's about good and
now it's about you know being fooled
with the story and just challenging the
characters and all the characters are
under intense pressure and so it's a
it's a time in which everyone has their
own specific reckoning and it's all
different it's like a lot going on I've
only watched it once and the first thing
is that I want to watch it again because
of the amount of information and Easter
eggs in there as well I think the thing
as well is that with them often with the
second chapter in a story of three
because the first one sets the tone and
the world and the new characters it
introduces them in the second one you
get to you don't have to spend so much
time doing that you can really just
delve into into the story into what's
happening like John said to the conflict
of each of the characters I think what
lion's done so incredibly well is that
he's challenged deeply every single
character including the droids you know
with like the biggest challenges they've
ever faced and and that's how you're
able to really get to to learn about
them on all sides of the spectrum from
light to dark you know it's like he's
found a way to get to the central that
central point of that character and try
to challenge them as best as you can I
think it's really I mean the biggest
thing to me when I read the script
because you know there's even though you
try and avoid what people are saying the
it's hard to and because people
responded well to John and I as a team I
was a bit nervous about not being a team
so much in this one so I think for me
personally it was more it was a
challenge the film was a challenge and
it was poke I know I don't know what it
was like for anyone else but to be in
different combinations of people so in
itself
we're already you know we're in
different situations were with different
people that we are learning about we're
meeting for the first time so yeah felt
very different for me let's hear from
the
guys the bad kids we sit in the back
[Laughter]
Gwendolyn Andy any thoughts on on just
the tone that how this movie
distinguishes itself among all the
different Star Wars films I mean I was
blown away when I saw the movie I just
was so caught up with it not not least
because it was really intimate and very
emotional and I wasn't expecting that at
all
I mean I mean I knew obviously that it
would that it was going to go that way
but it's very very powerful and it
touches you in what Ryan's not
incredibly is made this dance between
that you know totally dance you know
between these great kind of epic moments
and hilarious antics you know literally
flipping on a dime and then and then
going right into the heart of these
beautiful characters and and and you
really caring and I think that that was
for me I think has been you know that
was that's mine was my take away it was
just an extraordinary viewing I was
delighted by the film and what I was
surprised by was that Star Wars has
always been I think the reason why it's
resonated with us all so deeply is that
it's our foundation story of good
against evil and where that balance is
and how we see elements of characters
we've never seen before things that can
be unexpected but there is something
about this film and I think it's because
the world that we live in is it is a
changing and evolving place that it
retains the simplicity of those elements
but it it really resonates with what it
is
to follow your own human dark
narcissistic tendencies where that will
take you and I love that and it's it's
done so beautifully aesthetically - I
didn't go to the screening so he had a
thing
[Laughter]
was performing in it no that's why I
wanted I wanted to wait and see it with
huge crowd and see SM the way I saw the
the force awakens which was just with a
load of people losing their minds but
then I heard these guys lost their minds
though I was kind of annoyed I didn't go
[Laughter]
to Star Wars universe and that includes
you right you're the boss but you're
also I'm like the new boyfriend at
Thanksgiving dinner
no she's kind of the new boss she's a
new leader in the resistance is there a
little bit of your you in Admiral hold
oh I would be thrilled if there was
Laura during could represent any part of
me in life I would be thrilled
yeah hold it I mean I I mean Laura I've
been wanting to you know it's a dream to
just to get to work with her and the
character that she plays and all of its
glorious purple haired Wonder we were
really able to dig in and do some really
exciting fun stuff and Laura I know that
like in the moments on set where like
suddenly you would like catch my eye and
you would say this feels like we're
making an independent film like those
were the moments that I was like I'd
yeah it kind of does and I think that
feels really good and that kind of
intimacy of the process I think I don't
know if if Laura Dern's telling you that
then you might be on the right track I
guess yeah Laura I mean I know you're
there to do a job and be professional
but is there any part of you that geeks
out a little bit when you start working
on a Star Wars film every part I'm
trying not to cry right now because this
is so weird and different yeah I feel
like Ryan has said this before but it
definitely feels like you have to find a
way to just do the work and and kind of
block everything out but then c-3po
comes up and you're like oh
you're constantly figuring out how can I
figure out how to work in this
environment and then you're like but
also this is awesome so it's kind of a
balance right yeah yeah and and just to
add to that what Ryan spoke to that he
does so beautifully as well as as Andy
was describing the the intimacy of
discovering each character's conflict
which is just extraordinary given the
enormity of the cast that he gave us
that in the experience of the workplace
and it was shocking and Oscar and I
always talked about just the the how
stunned we were that we were in such a
massive environment and did feel like we
were you know making a indie movie and
you were always encouraging us to try
things and explore character and explore
this duality of the light in the dark
within characters the movie speaks to so
beautifully not just that there are
alternative universes but that not lies
within which seems to be the place that
George Lucas first started the mythology
of that and it's just so brilliant and a
group of us sitting together watching it
for the first time was amazing cuz it
was like we were with 3,000 people we
were your two characters Hux
in kylo Ren had a really interesting
relationship in the force awakens that I
understand is expanded on in this movie
where there or Snoke sort of plays them
against each other their allies but not
really I wondered if you two could talk
about their their their bond or lack
thereof as we enter this film I think
it's definitely there's a competition
and it's maybe yet to be discovered with
it
comes from I mean if anything I think
that's more of a testament to kind of
what everyone has been saying of Ryan's
ability to not mind a character in every
moment which seems like an obvious thing
but he doesn't so he knows that
spectacle won't mean anything if you
don't care about anything that's going
on with you again seems very obvious but
I think it's a really hard thing to
balance with this many moving parts and
this in the scale of something like this
it's so I love playing those scenes
especially with Donal because he's a
great great actor and there's no nothing
he's kind of taken for granted where you
know this happens and it moves on if
anything Ryan slows the pace and there's
not a moment that's taken for granted
it's always broken up into little pieces
and the story in our mind comes first
before an explosion that they have
that's dangerous water oh I don't know I
just I think it's funny you know like
there's just such a huge amount of drama
going on in that group of people but
then also just a huge amount of [ __ ]
infighting as well which I think it's
really fun to see them kind of really
hurt each other from the inside as well
as from the outside you know the United
Front thing is is difficult for them
sometimes but it was just there yeah I'm
not going to I think you know idea is
just a privilege to be to the audience
for some questions and just raise your
hand we have some microphones that are
going around and I'll try to call in as
many of you
as we can get lots of folks out there
let's ask this gentleman right here with
the goatee yeah my questions from our
camel with Luke training Rae in this
movie it seems like he's in the position
Yoda was with Luke and the Empire
Strikes Back is it sort of like what
your parents say you'll understand when
you're older does he finally you learned
some of Yoda's lessons now that he's the
teacher we're zooming that I trained Rey
sneaky you are I know I have to be
really careful people say was it
difficult to pick up and wield a
lightsaber again and I go do I I can
promise you my part is twice as big as
it wasn't for Neverland I love you all
this questions for mr. Johnson you had
said that a lot of the visual cues for
the last Jedi aware could be taken from
the Empire Strikes Back
what aesthetic really spoke to you about
Empire and what shot did you really want
to rub with him well I mean my same
photographer Stevie edlin who I've been
best friends who has since I was 18
years old we met in film school and so
to be standing next to each other and
the Star Wars said it was pretty surreal
but we I mean I think Empire is the you
know I think it's just the most
beautiful I mean all the films are
beautiful I think for my just taste I
think the cinematography and Empire is
the most gorgeous of the whole series
and so Steve and I looked at the
lighting in that it's also kind of the
most it's pretty daring in terms of how
dark they were willing to go with some
of it literally dark and how gorgeous
they were they went with some of the
choices they made the shaping of the
lighting but then in terms of like an
actual
visual esthetic I actually I made a
choice very early on that I thought well
I can either try and kind of copy my
idea of what the original movies did
which was much more of kind of a formal
the camera didn't move a ton and it was
much more of kind of the much more
formal type of type visual aesthetic or
I realized you know I we're gonna take
visual cues lighting wise and design
wise from you know the previous movies
but I need to just shoot this movie the
way that I would shoot a movie because
at the end of the day if I'm not engaged
with it and I'm not trying to tell the
story the way that really makes me
excited then it's not going to be up
there on the screen so I kind of cut
myself from loose camera movement wise
and shot wise from trying to imitate the
past and just try to tell the story as
exciting as excitingly this other work
as I could up on the screen yeah yeah so
there are way more female characters in
this movie certainly in the first three
movies that's gonna mean a lot to little
girls I want to know what it means to
you guys I think like as a girl growing
up in London obviously I knew there was
a disparity in films but I wasn't so
aware of it like growing up in a liberal
household I was never really made to
fill any one way so when I like like
when I got involved I didn't really like
I knew it was a big deal but the
response was so beyond anything I could
have imagined that I'm still like it was
only after so I was like oh oh yeah and
it's not like I ever took it for granted
or anything but it was just so
monumental the response and how people
felt about it
and obviously that's a testament to
Cathy JJ Michael Larry everyone who
created the characters in the beginning
and I think what's great about everyone
is it's not like she's a girl
this is a guy this as anything
everyone's just it's just great
characters that happily are falling into
broader categories now so I'm thrilled
yeah I agree I think that um it's it
feels like both an honor and a
responsibility at the same time I feel
like from the beginning when I initially
found out I got this role I just felt
like I wanted to do the whole thing
justice and I'm so excited that guys the
girls in this movie kick some butt every
single one is so good and I can't wait I
just want to pay tribute to Ryan for
being one of the most brilliantly
subversive filmmakers I've ever been
able to bear witness to and in the case
of the look of my character I was moved
by the fact that he really wanted her
strength to first lead with a very deep
femininity and to see a feat a powerful
female character also be feminine is
something that moves away from a
stereotype that's sometimes perceived in
strong female characters must be like
the boys I thought that was a really
interesting choice to get to witness I
was so delighted I wasn't cast in the
first Star Wars film yet when I heard
about the casting and I was utterly
delighted to see that there was a more
representative selection of actors that
were going to be in these incredible
Star Wars films and that has continued
and you know everything that my amazing
colleagues say is absolutely right you
get to see women that are not being
strong just because they're acting like
men they're doing something else and
also you're seeing a developed character
or at least a developing character
that's showing some complex character
traits and I'm just delighted about that
I'm delighted that something as as
legendary as Star Wars has decided to be
modern and to reflect our society more
as it is okay yes right here in the
front
this question goes out to Daisy Adam
John and Oscar last force awakens you
were the new kids on the block
you had Carrie Harrison and Mark to set
the tone and lead the way for you to
step into these roles you guys are now
leading the way for a next generation of
actors to come in to the Star Wars world
how much did that place any kind of onus
on you and any sense of responsibility
in addition to that inherent to your
performances so the lesson that I
learned from the first one from mark
Carrie Harrison is not so much telling
you and other people that I've worked
with is not telling you what your
experiences is gonna be because we're
all different and we see the world
differently that's kind of an obvious
thing but kind of similar to the almost
the question though before it it's it's
it's hard to impose an idea on someone
that you kind of don't know it's I think
it's everyone's relationship to it were
certainly within them I would imagine
this is different and that's that's kind
of for them to discover it's almost more
generous to you know give someone space
to make it personal to them I'm not
really sure what that means but what
more that they were they were kind of
let me tell you what it's gonna be like
cuz no one really knows and I think that
they would say even for them coming back
to the movies to this movie after so
many years that I think they I mean
maybe markets be better to this that
that even they have to figure out what
it means to them so I think that's a
very there kind of lead by example
people that's kind of what I'm avoiding
by saying because it's so cliched but
it's so it's more powerful I guess when
you see it in action so I think that
none of us took it upon ourselves to
tell people what how it was gonna be for
them because we're not them I don't know
that I'd that affected our performances
in any way I think everyone was just as
equally terrified to to figure out what
what we were doing you know make sure we
were looking at space next question get
somebody in the back there and the
question is is George made the original
trilogy very much we watched it through
the eyes of the eyes of r2d2 and c3po
through the droids and obviously here
we've got our two and three kyo and bb-8
and BP 90 so do we continue to see the
story through the eyes of the droids or
are they just passengers on this
adventure it's it's different they did
and it it was different than the force
awakens it's different in this also we
don't quite have so much the hidden
fortress kind of worm's-eye view of the
story that we started with in those
movies and with this yeah it just it
different story had different needs and
so we are much more kind of with our
leads the whole time I'll just quickly
add what I think is amazing about the
film is that every character III like
don't have a big film knowledge or
anything so I'm not ago this is so I
never understood the structure of what
the star was wasn't what anyone was
trying to fulfill so just as me watching
it I think you really follow the story
cuz you're with every character like
everything everything you need to see is
happening on screen you're not seeing
things happen off screen that have
happened off screen so people are asking
questions on screen they're getting
answers on screen they're having their
adventure on screen so you're with
everyone every step of the way so how
the story is unfolding and I think it
makes for compassionate viewing because
you're really understanding both sides
why people are doing the things they're
doing and how it's being fed from
everywhere and how things collide and
and the consequences of people's actions
how they directly affect
other people alright we'll take another
question there in the back the woman had
her hand up right there yes you a huge
Star Wars fan and I believe every movie
we walk away learning something and in
this particular one what is it that we
will be walking away learning again I
think that I mean again I think that's a
personal kind of thing it's the best way
that I can that I understand how seeing
in a dark room with people or total
strangers kind of works whether that be
a play or movies that no one lives in
the theater everyone has lives outside I
[Laughter]
kind of collective intelligence that
happens and what is rewarding about it
is realizing that you all are having a
different experience but at the same
time the same experience the story but
Brian one of the things that you and I
have talked about is that a theme that's
throughout the movie all the different
storylines is is the perils of meeting
your hero and living up to expectations
is that is that one thing that maybe
connects to her that's definitely one of
the things in it I mean that it's you
know I think these movies to some extent
are always about I don't know to really
boil it down it's you know if you look
back at and Lucas kind of you know
famously drawing from the hero's journey
myth that Joseph Campbell wrote about
and the hero's journey is not about
becoming a hero it's not about becoming
Hercules it's about really adolescents
it's about the transition from childhood
into adulthood and finding your place in
the world and you have these new powers
that you're feeling inside yourself for
the first time you don't know what to do
with them you don't know know who you're
going to get help from who's going to be
unreliable is not
navigating those are very tricky waters
that we all have to navigate that's why
it's so universal so part of that is is
you know your relationship to heroes and
people you thought were your heroes
people you don't expect to become your
heroes and that's definitely something
that that plays out in this film becomes
a hero and now return to that character
all these years later what what journey
without obviously giving it away but
what what arc is left for a guy who's
been through what Luke Skywalker has
been through I don't think any line in
the script to demise my reaction more
than this is not going to go the way you
think and Ryan pushed me out of my
comfort zone as if I weren't as
intimidated and terrified to begin with
but I'm grateful because you have to
trust someone and he was the only
obi-wan available to me not only in my
choices as an actor but my choices in
sauk where well I was so embarrassed I
look at my drab black socks and I said
curse you Ryan Johnson's going back
Monday another question
hi there so Laura mentioned this a bit
talking about that you felt it was more
of kind of an indie film sort of feel
and there's been a lot of questions and
just gonna throw this to anyone there's
been a lot of conversation and questions
about how this is like the other movies
what I want to know is how is it for you
how is it different than any of the
other movies it's longer
[Applause]
not much longer not much how do you feel
different um as an actor I would I would
much more easily draw comparison of
similarity because like I mean I'm sort
of just speaking for me that I was like
real new to this all and it was first
film and all that sort of stuff and
people I've done smaller films now this
year and I'm like genuinely it feels the
same
like the sets tend to be smaller with
shortened Prague instead of London but
like it genuinely it's a smooth not a
small feeling but it's a small it's like
that family thing so going into
something could have been really scary
and being surrounded by people that make
you feel really comfortable for me is
like the only thing you can ask for
because you can only do what you can do
if you're in a really safe environment
then you're able to do more and coming
back like it really felt it was
different obviously in ways because the
story is different the characters are
being challenged in different ways but
the crew was similar Ryan I think it
says a lot about Ryan and our first
Jamie actually like how a set is run is
so incredibly important and what JJ and
Tommy did first time around Ryan and
Jamie did this time it's just a really
happy set that everyone feels I think
heard and respected and and so just like
Anne in acting sense taking everything
away
I think the same feeling was captured of
love and of everyone trying to work
together to make this thing that
hopefully other people will love so I
think to me like in in a more an
emotional way I think it did feel more
similar than then different I'm Juan
Fernandez from an oil year Puerto Rico I
wanted to talk asked the director see
you at the celebration and all the
things that you participated to see that
you're a fan so I wanted to know at what
moment moment as a filmmaker whether it
was in the screenwriting process or
shooting something that you feel a
transition from fan or felt ownership as
a filmmaker of the Star Wars movie that
you were making oh I keep waiting for
that moment to have
even standing up here I see the big Star
Wars behind me and I'm like oh do we do
I belong under this yeah it feels very
there's no like Eureka moment where it's
like now I'm doing it you're always
riding that line between feeling like
you're a fan who snuck in the back gate
and is getting away with something which
i think is probably a good thing I'm
actually curious I'd be curious to hear
John just because you're the biggest fan
I know I'm still trying to get over a
kind of life because I think what we
forget is that when we filmed force
awakens it was about two years between
then before we started on on last Jedi
and we went off obviously to do other
stuff and then we come back he just
feels like yeah you're back in school
you know and own and it's been it's fun
every day was was a new set the
practical effects I think like doubled
on this film this movie that the sets
were bigger in it so he's always excited
and amazing but as everybody has said
you still feel were an intimacy when
you're doing these these scenes you know
an independent with a big budget
I love Oscar how you described yesterday
all of us watching the role at the top
as the lights went down yeah and even
though all of us feel giddy that we're
excited about being part of this we
suddenly you're an obsessed fan
regardless yeah that sounds great and
I'm wondering how impactful is that
without spoiling anything to the
characters who knew him in the last
movie and previous films I think we just
keeping it moving to be honest with you
man it's true the pressures on manage
you know there's no there's no time but
I think that's the one things were
unique to me about watching this movie
was
just a commentary on war I think there
has been a Star Wars movie end that has
explored war in the way the last Jedi
does it's very messy there the
categorizing of good and evil is it's
just this it's all mixed together so in
you know in terms of harm there's no you
know I'm sure we we all feel sentimental
with some wants to sit thin down sit ray
down but race off training she's got
stuff to do
I've got back injury I got stuff to do I
can't think about heart at the moment I
think it's reverberating but it's it's a
dire situation it's critical the
resistance is on slashed legs and you
know we're trying to survive first
orders right on top of us you know it's
everything is it is like war where you
got to just keep moving to try to
survive and so you feel I think the
momentum of everything that happened in
the force awakens just pushing and
getting to a critical mass in in this in
this film I will interject and I think
this is the beauty of having storylines
that are sort of happening in tand and
then affecting each other because I
would say that Ray at least is is very
much affected by it and I think like in
their in in the first bit like Ray is a
carrot has been alone for a really long
time and then and she's really open to
like love and friendship so Finn and BBI
come along and it's like this amazing
adventure and then how I'm like without
without trying to she she seeks
something from him because there's an
intimacy and there's a sort of figure of
something she's never dreamed of for her
that gets you know snatched away and
she's understanding everything is new to
her so she's understanding things in a
different way and and luckily for me
because I was trying to get to grips
with everything going on and then Ray's
trying to get to grips with everything
going on so if you're a at least there
is some time everything's moving forward
but she has some time to ask questions
and wonder what it is that leads people
to would have led someone to do
something like that
and also how that directly affects the
world around her because
yeah and then she you know she's worried
about Finn at home so I would say she is
maybe little more effective at least
emotionally on-screen then I don't want
anyone thinking going back to one of the
things about the question about you know
the strong women in it because as a guy
I'd like to say that for me
the most formative people in my life had
been women and and so that has shaped my
destiny destiny so much and so to see
that reflected in the film is really
really beautiful and it does it is more
true to real life and what's happening
now but what's always happened which is
you know it's they're the ones you know
yeah well speaking as the leader of the
first order
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oak is very unimpressed there is such a
huge female force that seems to be
growing in the universe and it's deeply
undermining this we see without giving
too much away a little snatcher in this
movie press conference going back to
Jenna's great question about women in
this film and in female characters and
Star Wars in general one of all for a
long time when I was growing up there
was really only one character and that
was Princess Leia and now general Leia
and of course Carrie Fisher isn't here
with us today except probably in spirit
giving everyone the finger from back
there but I wanted to ask the women in
this film about the impact that Princess
Leia had on generations of young girls
who were watching these movies even
though there weren't a whole lot there
wasn't a whole lot of variety for them I
think this is a character that that
spoke to them in Gwendoline speaking as
one of the as one of the idols of the
bad girls as as Captain phasma what what
did did lay a play in your life as a
young Star Wars fan
well she was very significant because I
was first shown a new hope when I was
six and I remember thinking wow that
character is really different I watched
TV and film obsessively from such a
young age but it stayed with me
throughout my formative years of she's
really interesting she's really smart
she's really funny she's she's
courageous she's bold she doesn't care
what people think and she isn't prepared
to be told what to do and she doesn't
look the same as a sort of homogenized
presentation of a woman that we had been
used to seeing so that was really
instrumental to me as someone that
didn't feel like they fitted that
homogenized view of what a woman was
supposed to be that there was
inspiration there that you could be an
individual and celebrates yourself and
be successful without without giving
yourself over without necessarily making
some sort of terrible huge compromise so
it was a big inspiration for me and you
know to play a character as well from
what we've seen in the force awakens I
was very excited when I was shown just
the basic element of the costume and
here we were seeing character whereby a
woman wasn't her femininity was not
delineating in terms of the shape of her
body in terms of her physical
attractiveness those elements that weird
random group of elements which were born
with it's some kind of odd lottery and
then we're judged on in society and I
was just delighted to be able to have
that opportunity any other
Laura how about you do you have any
thoughts on the impact of Carrie Fisher
and Princess Leia and in pop culture
engine well endless thoughts and and
also you know a profound impact that she
made on me as a girl I mean spoken so
beautifully by Gwen so I I'll just speak
to this present experience to say that
as we always had with Carrie not just
Leia her wisdom and you know people
speak about people who are brave or
fearless but beyond that I've known
luckily a few people that would hold
those descriptions but not that they
would be without shame and that's what
moved me the most about they the icon
she gave us but also what she gave us
individually and personally which is to
carry who she was so directly and to be
without shame and to share her story and
to expect nothing less from any of us
and the privilege of watching how Ryan
has so beautifully captured all of that
and her grace and this amazing beautiful
pure performance but also I think she
found an equal irreverence subversive
and they had this dance that gives us
this performance that I was just so well
how about Daisy and Kelly any thoughts
on the legacy of Leia and Carrie I don't
think I can really follow that except to
just say Carrie's daughter Billie is I
think all of those qualities she's smart
and funny and shameless and one way
I think if Kari bringing up her a
daughter obviously with Brian bringing
up a daughter who is all of those
qualities and then some in this world if
that's what she did you know just her
being her I think it speaks volumes to
what she did as her in in the spotlight
and also her as Leia
yeah I mean I agree with everything that
was said I think that something about
Kari that I really look up to is and
something I didn't realize until
recently it was just how much courage it
takes to truly be yourself when you're
on a public platform or when possibly a
lot of people will be looking at you and
she was so unapologetic and so openly
herself and that is something that I am
really trying to do and it's hard and
just like Daisy said lorrison like
Wendelin said I think that she will
always be an icon as Leia but also as
Carrie what an example you know and I am
so fortunate to have met her and I think
that she will really live on forever
thank you guys so much for being here
thank you for all the wonderful
questions audience the cast of Star Wars
the last Jedi
you